I'm doing what are you busy we're good I
know it's a big day night I know have
you had a me-too moment in your life uh
yes I
I don't believe that I know any woman
who has not yeah it's true that is you
know it's something that I never really
talked about and it's because of people
like Ashley Judd and Rose McGowan and
some hayek to me the list is so long
that station finally started happening
and you realize oh my god this is a
systemic problem this is a societal
issue and it's it's not just Hollywood
it is across all industries globally and
you know we need to get we need balance
in in our boardrooms we want 5050 by
2020 50% women 50% men in all
decision-making roles and we really
believe that once that happens once once
the workforce and the work that we do
here the storytelling reflects the real
world the incidence of the harassment
and sexual assault will go down and it
tonight is also about celebrating Will
and Grace
it is my gosh you guys come back after
this long time away and then you're
nominated it really it really is
something that I don't think any of us
imagined was possible 11 years
and you know we've done seven episodes
and to be here again being celebrated
for the work it's um it's the best of
all possibilities really I know you
the show is but now has like 27
nominations tonight is 29 28 27 before
tonight you got two more tonight and
zero wins so tonight maybe as a night
and well my grace is gonna win I sure
hope so
you